rock and roll it really is a magical  thing  this is it it's not just any hall of  fame it's the [ __ ] rock and roll hall  of fame  [Applause]  make some noise for my man l cool j i  want to thank all of you  the go-go's beauty and the beat blew the  doors of my life off we love you and you  will always be in our heart it's just  unbelievable  carol king is the greatest songwriter of  all time she's inspired us all so much  oh thank you thank you  being black in america not as easy as it  looks  [Applause]  i went to every single record company  and you know what they said right that  [ __ ] is trash  i for not one second changed my course  now that's rock and roll  tina turner is who we're here tonight to  celebrate  [Music]  [Applause]  food fighters this band is one of the  greatest rock and roll bands thank you  all very much for hanging out with us  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you